- Le couvre feu,
est-ce que c'est le cas ?
- Ce qu'on appelle le couvre-feu
est une mesure qui est...
Salut !
Alors j'ai d'habitude,
quand il y a une interview importante
d'Emmanuel Macron, maintenant,
dans la seconde vous me demandez
quand est-ce que sort l'analyse.
Je le fais pas
systématiquement,
mais là je trouvais ça
intéressant de le faire.
Donc son interview
a eu lieu hier soir,
je ne l'ai pas regardée,
non pas parce que je voulais pas
la regarder à l'avance.
Mais parce que j'étais au spectacle,
à la première d'un copain.
Qui du coup est sa dernière aussi.
Mais Loïc l'a regardée et il m'a dit :
"Ah ça doit valoir le coup de faire ça".
C'est ce que tu m'as dit Loïc.
- Exact.
- Donc on fait ça aujourd'hui.
Evidemment ce couvre-feu
a des répercussions
sur mes spectacles
le Zénith et la tournée,
ça je vous en parlerai à la fin
si vous êtes concernés
et intéressés par mes spectacles.
Parce que sinon
vous vous en foutez.
Donc je vais pas
vous saouler avec ça.
Et enfin, avant de commencer
un petit disclaimer
regardez le si c'est la première fois
que vous voyez une de mes analyses,
si vous avez l'habitude de ça,
vous pouvez sauter,
vous allez voir le petit curseur
qui va bien vous aider.
Disclaimer !
Le travail que je vais faire,
à savoir analyser les réactions
d'Emmanuel Macron
pendant le discours verbal,
non-verbal, paraverbal,
c'est à dire tout qu'il dit
avec son corps ou avec sa bouche,
c'est un travail qui est forcément
subjectif, je suis mentaliste
ça veut dire que je ne suis pas
expert d'un domaine particulier,
que c'est pas de la science dure.
Que je vais m'appuyer
sur tout ce que je peux
pour essayer de faire
des interprétations
qui ne restent que des hypothèses,
mes hypothèses,
c'est complètement subjectif,
c'est pas de la science
ne citez pas un extrait de cette vidéo
sans mettre un bout de ce disclaimer,
parce que ça c'est pas cool,
parce que je précise toujours ça
avant chaque vidéo,
que des fois je vais taper
dans un bout de science
ou dans un bout
de pseudo science
pour essayer d'étayer
une hypothèse.
Ni plus ni moins.
Eh du coup c'est parti.
- Est-ce qu'on a perdu
le contrôle de l'épidémie ?
- Bonsoir...
- Alors on peut regarder déjà
la position de départ.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle nous dit
cette position de départ ?
Parce qu'elle est forcément
travaillée et réfléchie en amont,
il ne se met pas au hasard comme ça
en mode manspreading.
J'attends de voir
ce qui se passe.
On a la distanciation vis-à-vis d'eux,
mais ça c'est normal,
c'est par rapport
aux gestes barrières.
On a quelqu'un qui a bien
travaillé sa stature,
qui est bien assis,
qui est bien posé,
qui met la main droite
sur la main gauche.
C'est à dire, il est prêt à agir
puisque sa main droite est libre.
Et puis on a une forme de contrôle
déjà qui est tout à fait prête,
mais ça ne parait pas
déconnant en fait
par rapport à ce qu'il a
à nous dire.
Il vient forcément
pour faire une annonce,
il vient pas pour nous dire :
"ça va vous en ce moment ?".
On sait qu'il y a quelque chose
qui se trame, tout le monde le sait.
- Toute l'Europe,
le monde entier même.
Nous avons eu,
durant cette première vague,
30 000 victimes.
Depuis lors, 2 000 victimes
supplémentaires.
Et en effet, ce virus
que nous connaissons maintenant
depuis le début de l'année,
qui nous frappe depuis
huit mois, revient.
Nous sommes dans
ce qu'on a souvent appelé,
cette deuxième vague.
L'OMS le rappelait ce matin,
0,6% des gens qui sont touchés,
32 000 victimes en France.
Il tue plus tôt les gens
qui sont plus âgés...
- Pour l'instant y'a pas
grand chose à dire,
on est dans une attitude de :
"Je me pré-justifie
de ce que je vais dire".
La construction de toute manière,
de son texte est comme ça.
Et il l'incarne parfaitement,
c'est à dire qu'il le joue en partie.
Il le joue de : "Croyez-moi".
On le voit toujours à l'expression
des sourcils levés
et on voit les plis
comme ça sur son front,
avec beaucoup de gestes
pour bien séparer
le passé du futur
et poser les choses.
On l'a vu plein de fois
faire ce geste.
On est vraiment sur :
"Regardez les bases,
ça c'est les bases
retenez les, elles sont importantes,
elles sont graves,
parce que ça va justifier
ce que je vais vous dire après
et vous ne pourrez pas le réfuter".
En l'occurrence, il fait ce travail là
pour le moment.
- Il frappe plutôt celles et ceux qui ont
aussi d'autres pathologies, diabète...
- Il garde toujours
cette expression de visage.
- De l'hypertension,
de l'obésité mais...
- Avec les sourcils,
Avec les sourcils,
légèrement affectés.
Vous voyez ce que
je veux vous dire,
c'est que c'est vraiment important
ce que je viens de vous dire
il faut être empathique avec ça.
Je sais pas si
c'est volontaire ou pas,
mais le fait d'avoir
cette expression de visage,
ça permet d'essayer de
solliciter les neurones miroirs
de l'interlocuteur pour
qu'il ressente la même émotion.
je pense pas que ça a été travaillé
quand même à ce point là,
mais en tout cas,
c'est ce que ça va générer.
- Cela et en mourir et il frappe
de manière très injuste.
Encore plus dans les milieux
les plus précaires, les plus pauvres.
Mais une fois que j'ai dit ça.
Ce virus frappe toutes
les catégories d'âge
et il y a des formes
très sévères à tous les âges.
Au moment où je vous parle.
Nous y reviendront.
La moitié de nos...
La moitié du nombre de COVID
qui sont en réanimation
ont moins de 65 ans.
Au moment où je vous parle,
nous avons des centaines de milliers
de nos concitoyens
qui ont eu ce virus.
- C'est assez intéressant
de se dire qu'il a travaillé
l'eye contact,
le contact regard à ce point.
Parce que j'imagine bien
qu'il est pas en train d'improviser
donc ça veut dire qu'il a travaillé
ce discours et que ça a été volontaire,
en termes de communication
de se dire :
"je vais regarder les deux journalistes
dans les yeux un par un".
Parce que nous
de l'autre côté de l'écran,
on peut s'identifier à ces journalistes
là comme si on lui parlait,
comme si on discutait ensemble,
alors que c'est pas tellement
une discussion
puisque ils lui donnent des "go"
sur les sujets et lui se lance dessus.
Je pense même que
ça a été validé en fait,
entre l'Elysée et les journalistes
la manière de se dérouler.
Mais voilà, lui a décidé
de ne pas faire un face caméra
avec un sous-titrage etc,
comme on a l'habitude de le voir.
Pourquoi, je pense que c'est vraiment
pour qu'on puisse nous,
s'identifier et trouver quelque chose
de plus naturel en fait.
Et de moins solennelle,
de moins violent
qu'une annonce présidentielle,
ce qu'on appelle
les allocutions habituellement.
Pour l'instant d'ailleurs
il regarde beaucoup plus souvent
la journaliste que le journaliste.
J'arrive pas tellement
à savoir pourquoi,
il faudrait que
j'ai plus de plans sur elle,
peut-être qu'elle a le visage
plus fermé ou plus dubitatif
et que du coup
il se dit inconsciemment :
"il faut que j'arrive à la convaincre
parce que lui a l'air plus convaincu".
ça c'est une hypothèse sur l'hypothèse,
c'est vraiment, j'en sais rien.
- En ce moment, nous avons 20 000
cas en moyenne par jour de plus.
20 000.
- Alors ça, ça c'est du paraverbal.
On pourrait dire
ses intonations de faire :
"nous avons 20 000 cas
en moyenne de plus par jour.
20 000 cas".
C'est à dire qu'il utilise
les deux extrêmes
de l'intensité de prononciation,
pour nous marquer d'un coup du :
"c'est très grave et très dangereux
et c'est quand même terrible
ce qu'il se passe".
je sais pas comment,
s'il est coaché ou pas, etc.
Mais en tout cas pour nous convaincre,
il n'y a pas mieux que de faire ça.
Et je ne dis pas qu'il faille
nous convaincre du nombre de cas,
parce que on sait très bien
que c'est vrai
et que évidemment ça fait
énormément de personnes.
Mais c'est marrant
de le voir par contre,
nuancer en termes d'intonation
de ces mots là,
pour les mettre en valeur
en gras dans le texte
et après leur donner une seconde
intention émotionnelle.
- Je vous parlais depuis
plusieurs jours,
nous avons chaque jour
200 de nos concitoyens
qui rentrent en réanimation.
Aujourd'hui, 226.
Et nous avons...
- Il vient de faire la même chose
avec les 200 concitoyens par jour,
aujourd'hui 226.
Donc s'il le fait à chaque fois,
c'est que ce n'est
peut-être pas un hasard.
Et surtout il s'est pas laissé faire
pour se faire couper la parole,
parce que ça allait arriver.
Parce que le texte est tellement
travaillé en termes d'argumentation
et en termes de si A égal B,
si B égal C, alors A égal C,
c'est comme ça qu'il va
nous convaincre en fait,
de la légitimité de la décision.
Mais c'est normal.
C'est son travail.
Eh bien si on le coupe dedans
et qu'il répond à une autre question,
ça va dévier de sa démonstration.
On appelle ça vraiment
une démonstration d'ailleurs.
- Et ce qui est important
de comprendre
et je m'arrêterai là sur ce point,
c'est que la différence
entre le moment où...
- Là aussi, c'est magnifique.
"Ce qui est important de comprendre".
On a vraiment le geste de la pitié.
ça veut dire : "s'il vous plaît croyez-moi,
je vous je vous en prie", en fait.
Vous savez exactement
ce que veut dire ce geste.
Le fait qu'on l'ait vu
passer n'est pas anodin.
- Il se dit depuis plusieurs jours
que vous avez opté
pour cette option là, le couvre-feu.
Est-ce que c'est le cas ?
- Oui, mais je vais d'un mot
vous expliquer
d'abord pourquoi on agit tous
et pourquoi on fait ça.
- C'est assez marrant, parce que
j'ai cru l'espace d'un instant, qu'il avait
un ou deux signes de colère de :
"mince il me force à parler
du couvre-feu tout de suite".
Mais en fait je me dis
c'est pas cohérent
parce que déjà encore une fois,
l'Elysée voit les questions
passer avant etc.
Ils l'auraient vu
si c'était problématique.
Mais surtout, on n'a pas tous
les symboles de la colère en fait.
ça ressemble à une colère
mais c'est pas une colère.
En fait, c'est quelqu'un qui veut donner
le visage de quelqu'un de :
"Je suis concerné, c'est important".
Et c'est pour ça
que ça ressemble à de la colère,
parce qu'on fronce un peu les sourcils,
on entrouvre la bouche.
Mais on n'a pas
la crispation de la mâchoire.
On n'a pas de changement
au niveau de l'ouverture des yeux,
donc ce n'est pas de la colère
c'est juste :
"ça c'est important".
Et d'ailleurs on l'a vu
se redresser très légèrement.
- Donc ça c'est notre objectif.
Et cet objectif de manière
très concrète, c'est freiner le virus,
c'est faire que ces 20 000
nouveaux cas par jour,
on va devoir les ramener
à trois à 5 000 cas par jour.
Parce que là on peut maîtriser.
C'est que ces
200 entrées en réanimation,
on doit aussi fortement les réduire
pour au fond revenir à un niveau...
- Okay là il est sur un moment
de tension très important
parce qu'il donne les chiffres
et les objectifs avec.
Il check juste avant les chiffres,
pour ne pas dire de bêtises.
Donc ça veut dire
que on est sûrs qu'il les connaît
et qu'il ne dit pas n'importe quoi
à ce moment là.
Vous voyez le coup de tête
qu'il fait là.
Et qu'il va refaire en fait,
il va beaucoup alterner
entre les deux journalistes.
On alterne pas quand on est en train
de dire une phrase comme ça,
on alterne pas
de cette manière là.
Moi ça me rappelle un truc,
alors attention à ce que je vais dire,
n'isolez pas ça s'il vous plaît,
parce que c'est un tout
cette phrase.
Quand quelqu'un ment,
je vous ai toujours dit
il a tendance à regarder
dans les yeux,
parce qu'il a besoin de voir
si la personne valide son mensonge.
Je dis pas du tout
qu'Emmanuel Macron
ment à ce moment là.
Ce que je dis, c'est que
il a vraiment besoin de voir
dans le regard des journalistes
qu'ils le croient
dans ce qu'il est en train de dire.
Parce qu'il va voir s'il est assez
convaincant à travers leur regard.
Autant cette configuration
est sûrement là
pour qu'on s'identifie
aux journalistes, autant lui,
Emmanuel Macron doit identifier
nous, les citoyens aux journalistes.
Et je pense que c'est vraiment,
il est en train inconsciemment
d'essayer d'analyser leur regard.
C'est sûr que là
il est en relâchement.
ça n'a pas été pensé en amont
le fait d'avoir cette attitude là,
regardez bien.
- On va devoir les ramener
à trois à 5 000 cas par jour
parce que là on peut maîtriser.
C'est que ces 200 entrées
en réanimation
- Là il a checké, donc là il le dit.
on doit aussi fortement les réduire
pour au fond, revenir...
- Et c'est fou, parce que au tout début
je me suis dit au premier visionnage,
ça se trouve il leur a dit ça parce qu'il
est plus sûr des chiffres qu'il donne.
Mais non puisqu'on a bien vu,
il donne le regard
juste avant dessus.
Donc il a besoin de voir
s'ils valident ça ou pas
mais c'est assez dur
de voir quelque chose
là pour le coup sur Anne-Sophie Lapix
qui le laisse dérouler, en mode
"Vas-y raconte et après
je donnerai mon avis peut-être".
- Et donc la décision
que nous avons prise,
c'est en effet un couvre-feu.
- Il y avait un vrai désolé là...
- Un couvre-feu qui va s'appliquer à...
- Qui est passé à l'image.
Là c'est marrant parce que vraiment
il a préparé tout le terrain,
on sait qu'il va parler du couvre-feu,
on sait qu'il va l'annoncer
Mais on sait qu'il est quand même
pas hyper à l'aise avec ça
et qu'il redoute en fait
les répercussions de ça.
On a vraiment ce visage là,
"Après la décision
que nous avons prise".
Où t'as ce "désolé,
il fallait qu'on fasse un truc,
on a fait ça quoi".
Le virus circule très activement...
- Et on voit au bafouillage,
qu'il n'est pas sur ses appuis là.
- Collectivement
responsables justement,
d'un engagement collectif
de réduction de ses contacts.
A ce moment là...
- Mais il y a presque de la peur là.
On n'est pas bien, bien, bien
quand même là.
On n'est pas bien là dessus.
Je sais pas pourquoi
il est si mal là dessus.
Est-ce que c'est parce que lui il a
une autre durée qui est prévue en tête ?
Ce qui était un peu le cas
déjà durant le confinement,
quand il nous avait annoncé
les 15 jours.
Dans la vidéo je disais :
"Là c'est pas 15 jours qu'il annonce".
On l'a bien vu ce que ça a fait.
Là j'ai l'impression
que c'est pareil,
alors est-ce que c'est la peur de
devoir reconfiner quoi qu'il arrive,
ou de devoir durcir ce couvre feu
ou de devoir le faire durer
beaucoup plus longtemps.
Je sais pas, mais on n'est pas
sur quelqu'un qui est à l'aise
surtout que là
il parle pas pour parler,
il va refermer la bouche
pour reprendre après sa conversation.
- A ce moment là,
nous pensons que nous pourrons
progressivement rouvrir.
Je suis très prudent
parce que l'expérience
nous enseigne
qu'on ne maîtrise pas tout,
qu'on ne sait pas tout dire.
Mais six semaines,
c'est le temps qui nous paraît utile.
Je veux bien simplement que...
- Là il vient de se refermer
corporellement.
C'est à dire, ça veut dire :
"Ne me mettez pas des coups à moi,
en fait je ne maîtrise pas tout".
Vous le voyez très bien.
Si tu peux le remettre
un petit coup Lolo.
- Progressivement rouvrir,
je suis très prudent
parce que l'expérience
nous enseigne qu'on ne maîtrise
pas tout, qu'on ne sait pas tout dire.
- Merci Lolo.
- On va essayer d'aider
au maximum.
Par exemple pour
les théâtres, les cinémas
à pouvoir avoir
des reprogrammations,
organiser les choses,
pour pouvoir y aller
un peu plus tôt.
- Là je parle pour ma partie,
j'ai vu personne du gouvernement
venir nous aider à
reprogrammer les spectacles.
Je dis ça un peu en mode vanne,
mais quand j'entends :
"On va essayer d'accompagner
pour aider les choses
à être reprogrammées
dans le temps".
Bah en vrai, on sort les rames.
Je ne vois pas comment
ils peuvent nous aider là dessus.
ça c'est vraiment un avis
très perso dans le truc,
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'analyse
mais je trouvais ça rigolo de le dire.
- Il ne s'en sort pas en fermant à 21h,
on l'accompagnera.
- Je voudrais qu'on en revienne
très concrètement aux restrictions...
Il était un peu K.O là, à la fin.
C'était son temps fort
de la démonstration,
on a vu le visage à la fin de,
Il a fini son round.
- Valable, y aura t-il des attestations
comme pendant le confinement,
y aura-t-il des applications
sur téléphones portables ?
- Il a passé le gros du truc
et il est pas tant que ça
plus détendu,
mais il tient un peu moins son visage
et on voit qu'il est en récupération,
parce qu'il sait que maintenant,
qu'il a donné le gros de la chose,
on va lui poser
des questions sur les détails.
Et les détails,
il le gère ou il le gère pas,
c'est pas hyper important en fait.
- Des attestations comme
pendant le confinement...
- D'où ce relâchement,
il est même capable de porter
la main au visage,
chose qu'il n'a jamais faite
en 15 minutes là pour l'instant.
- Des applications sur
téléphone portable.
Comment ça va se passer ?
- Oui exactement, comme cela
- Dès samedi matin...
- Regardez juste avant sa réponse.
C'est, "bon alors,
je suis en récupération
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer ?
Les attestations, ah oui ça
ça c'est tranquille ça !".
On le voit vraiment
dans l'engouement
et la non retenue
quand il se relève.
- Comment ça va se passer ?
- Oui exactement, comme cela
- Pour traiter ces tests
en moins deux jours
parce que au-delà de deux jours,
c'était de l'argent jeté par les fenêtres.
- Alors vous avez raison, on a rencontré
des vraies difficultés sur ce sujet.
Et je crois qu'il faut le dire
et les partager.
Pourquoi...
- Je pense qu'inconsciemment
il a senti ses mains partir un peu,
parce que là il a eu
un petit shot d'adrénaline
dans le sang quand même,
de stress.
Donc il a senti ses mains,
"Je bloque, je reprends la position
qu'on m'a dit de prendre pour bloquer".
- On est aujourd'hui l'un des pays
qui teste plus en Europe.
- Pas forcément
le plus efficacement.
- Mais je vais y revenir pourquoi ?
Parce que ça,
c'est les techniques de test.
Mais on fait entre
1,2 et 1,4 million.
Et quand je regarde
ces derniers jours,
parce que vous comprendrez bien
que je surveille quotidiennement
avec que les ministres.
- Ils l'ont "punché" à deux.
Je pense que c'est la partie
où les questions
n'étaient pas attendues en fait.
Et c'est hyper intéressant d'ailleurs,
Anne-Sophie Lapix
s'en amuse un peu, on le voit là.
Mais il a été remis
à mal par l'autre journaliste,
alors que depuis le départ,
on le voyait aller chercher
plutôt du soutien
quand il allait le voir
dans son regard.
Et il a fait gauche-droite,
il ne sait plus,
il a centré, il a reposé les coudes,
il s'est un peu affaissé.
Et là il est en train
de construire sa stratégie
et de se reprendre
et il va se relever.
Mais on est vraiment sur
un petit combat de boxe aujourd'hui.
- Vous pensez que la solution
c'était de rendre payant le test ?
Moi, je crois pas.
- Je ne dis pas ça, c'est de prévoir
les moyens pour analyser
- J'assume totalement,
j'assume totalement qu'on ait,
en effet rendu le test gratuit.
- Sa manière de gagner du temps,
là c'est dans le verbal,
mais c'est intéressant
c'est juste fou en fait.
Elle lui pose une question
sur la manière d'analyser les tests.
Et lui il redéplace le problème
comme s'il se faisait attaquer
sur le fait que le test soit gratuit.
Il dit : "Mais vous trouveriez
ça normal, vous
qu'on doive faire payer les tests ?".
Donc elle dit : "Non, non, non"
et puis c'est même pas la question.
Parce qu'il fait :
"Parce que moi, je trouverais ça
complètement anormal".
Il s'en défend tel un justicier.
Et on se dit :
"Okay, c'est vrai
on est d'accord avec lui".
Mais c'est pas du tout la question
qui a été posée au préalable.
C'est une vraie stratégie de défense,
de langue de bois.
- Qui aurait pas de barrière
à l'argent, il faut le dire.
Et depuis le début de cette crise
c'est ce qu'on a fait.
- Et il s'en énerve,
faussement, bien-sûr.
- On est un des pays qui a
le plus accompagné
économiquement et socialement.
- Je pense qu'on a
regardé ce qu'il fallait,
t'en penses quoi Loïc ?
- Moi je pense que pas du tout.
- Non mais en vrai, tu penses que oui ?
- je pense qu'on a fait le...
- Ouais.
Eh ben, écoutez, on va s'arrêter là.
On en a déjà eu pas mal.
C'était intéressant en fait,
du coup je suis content de l'avoir vu,
je ne pensais pas du tout
que c'était cette "config" là.
Je parle à Loïc, excusez moi.
Mais je pensais vraiment que
c'était en mode allocution.
En fait, je n'avais pas compris
que c'était avec
deux journalistes comme ça.
Ce qui donnait une vraie
matière à analyser,
différente de d'habitude.
donc je suis très content que
Loïc ait pensé à me dire :
"Fais l'analyse
d'Emmanuel Macron".
- Il n'y pas de problème.
- Ah mais je rends à César
ce qui est à Loïc, du coup.
Mais c'est l'anagramme de César
avec des lettres différentes.
- Exactement, "fférente"
- "Fférente"
C'était joli ça.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette nouvelle analyse,
j'espère que ça, ça vous a plu.
N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo,
à me faire vos analyses
à vous aussi dans les commentaires,
en étant dans le respect
s'il vous plaît.
Que quel que soit
votre bord politique
ou ce que vous pensiez
de la situation.
Argumentez et soyez respectueux
et on balance pas de fake news
ou autre chose comme ça.
C'est tout ce que
je vous demande.
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à cette chaîne,
c'est gratuit parce que
c'est quelque chose
qui me tenait à cœur,
la gratuité sur le...
J'arrête, je déconne.
Concernant le spectacle,
je vous en dis plus lundi.
Mais grosso modo, on sait aujourd'hui
qu'on pourra pas faire le zénith
en temps et en heure
le 20 novembre.
Là c'est plus possible
avec le couvre-feu
et avec tout ce que
ça implique en fait, dedans.
ça fait tomber plein de dominos,
je vous raconterai ça un peu plus tard.
Mais on va le décaler
au 19 juin 2021,
vos billets restent valables.
Donc ça c'est très cool.
Peut-être en plus,
il n'y aura plus de masques
et de distanciation
au mois de juin,
on croise les doigts
pour ça également.
Donc ce sera le 19 juin 2021.
Et pour la petite histoire,
ben il y a un truc positif,
c'est qu'à la base le zénith
devait être la dernière date
de mon spectacle "singularité".
Après ce spectacle n'existe plus.
A cause du confinement
et du décalage de la tournée,
c'était plus la dernière date,
parce qu'il y avait au moins
50 représentations derrière.
Eh bien là, ça redevient
la toute dernière date.
Donc au moins,
je suis très triste
de ne pas pouvoir le faire
le 20 novembre,
soyons très clairs.
Mais au moins je me dis au moins,
ce sera une jolie fin de l'histoire
pour ce spectacle
de terminer au Zénith
comme prévu.
Pour les dates de tournée,
sur les villes impactées
telles que Lille, Grenoble, etc.
Vous avez toutes les infos
sur mon site internet.
Et pareil je vous en reparle
un petit peu plus lundi.
Mais Lille par exemple,
qui était complet avant le confinement,
je devais jouer deux fois d'affilée
là, le 23 novembre.
ça va peut-être être reporté.
Pour toutes les autres villes
qui ne font pas partie du couvre feu,
il n'y a aucun souci ça tient,
vous pouvez prendre vos places
comme d'habitude et ça ça roule.
Merci encore d'avoir
regardé cette analyse.
Ici, je vous mets
une analyse de à posteriori,
parce que ça c'est intéressant
des différentes choses.
Et là je vous mets une analyse
du professeur Raoult,
parce que c'était la dernière
qui était sortie.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !